absolutely because the individuals who
sent our country to war were not
historians who understood the complex
history of the region or social cultural
anthropologists who knew the cultural
linguistic and religious issues that
were involved in or were they linguists
who understood the language and I think
we went to Afghanistan and trusted
locals who had huge financial incentives
to gain by turning one another in and we
hadn't done our research in in the area
and I don't believe it was done
maliciously I feel that fear and anger
was at its peak in the United States
following September 11th because this
was a spectacular event where you know
3,000 Americans were killed and we were
seeing this on TV day in and day out 50
times a day for weeks though that said I
do believe that with our fear and anger
we were ignorant in the regional
complexities of Iraq and Afghanistan